facebook accuses apple of
anti-competitive behavior over privacy
by the way that's very interesting if
you when you get into it facebook uh
talks about wednesday after irony here
firing another shot in a month-long
standoff between the two tech giants
over apple's plan privacy changes on ios
14
apple is behaving anti-competitively by
using their control of the app store to
benefit their bottom line at the expense
of creators and small businesses
full stop facebook vice president for
ads and business products
dan levy told reporters the world's
biggest social media company
ran full-page ads and major newspapers
criticizing apple's plan
which will limit apps ability to gather
data from other phones
that will be used for targeting
advertising apple said in june that such
activity will require a pop-up
notification asking ios users for
permission to track your
you across apps and websites owned by
other companies which digital
advertising firms expect most
will decline facebook and apple have
also tangled over commission fees the
iphone maker charges apps
listed on ios devices with facebook
again aligning itself with small
developers most affected by this policy
thoughts
well we we we all saw what happened with
apple and epic games and fortnite and
everything with that and that was
something we covered on the top on the
podcast yeah many times
but something that a theme of this
podcast that we've had this entire time
is competition
and holding other states or countries
accountable
to see apple and facebook go at it
i freaking love it two legitimate
monopolies right now yeah exactly all
right so we
we said that you know apple is on the
verge of what forty
six percent forty six percent
facebook is currently dealing with
anti-trust lawsuits are there i mean
biden's trying to get him to uh break
apart with whatsapp and instagram
i you know amazon vs walmart
who's winning that one for me i i'm not
trying to get two in the technic they're
taking out
full-page ads like to see apple and
facebook
go at it i can appreciate that the
question is
who's more powerful who's an actually
more powerful company apple
or facebook again you know
the my mom hat is on right now and i
think privacy is a big issue
so you're you're going with uh you're
defending apple i think i think you
should be as
private as you want to be yeah and i
think you should know
if somebody's infringing upon your
privacy i don't think that that should
be something that you have to
find out by watching the social dilemma
you're like whoa
no no no i think privacy is a bigger
issue than what we
appreciate and i think people like the
the the kid in vermont who's been
who's been holed up for seven months
somebody's
following him somebody's tracking
everything and
and they're preying upon his weaknesses
yep
they are they're infringing upon his
privacy i see what you're saying so
they're bringing up the videos that he
will you know take him to the rabbit
hole
they're praying so i i think privacy uh
i i don't think that's something that
america
has explored deeply enough so i'm
curious if you're watching this right
now who who are you
defending are you with danielle on apple
if you are smash the thumbs up button if
you're saying no
i think facebook should be allowed to
target whoever they want to target with
their ads because if they don't they're
going to be
hitting some revenue issues put thumbs
down but thumbs up for apple thumbs down
to defend facebook i'm curious you know
what you guys will say about it
adam what are your thoughts on on this
topic
i'd just love to see these two companies
going at it i don't know if there's any
clear-cut answers
that's your oh come on these are moral
issues you're talking about put so much
time into creating opinions about these
issues adam like seriously
this is this is something where i just
think i i love that these two companies
are holding each other accountable i
like it we're gonna have to get you some
children
i would like some daniel okay i think
you're gonna make an
awesome i'm still thinking about tom
cruise bro i think you're gonna make it
awesome well he's not gonna help you
make children yeah no that's
he is definitely your top ten though no
question he's in your top two that's
impressive this is number one though
who's number one dicaprio's probably
gonna be yeah
he's probably a top three guy freaking
guy you know he's
kissed only one girl in his life but
okay so let's go back to this facebook
clooney okay period cool there you go
cool yeah george cronin i think there's
something about robert downey jr with
you know it's very very cool and
different denzel's a freaking badass guy
that's just like a dance mask
yeah i don't know about you guys so well
jackson kind of so how do we go
i talk facebook apple you're going to
sexy man like what is up with adam today
you're all over the place like you've
been salivating you've text
i got six emails this morning waking up
saying adam wants you to cover tom
cruise
so we covered it for you let's get that
out of your system he's celebrating
christmas kwanzaa and hanukkah so he's
like the happiest guy in the room yeah
maybe we should take a look at his
search history and we'd understand we
would if we could
facebook well no it would be uh what's
the other one it would be uh just just
as facebook
what is the other one that we were
talking about last time the search
history what's that one company where
you get five bucks for pizza or whatever
what is it
this is only fans only fans your website
that's where you go live okay the girls
i was talking to in miami it turns out
she was an only fan account and now i'm
just maybe she was hoping for you to be
her only fan
maybe that's what it was i don't know
that's a play i don't know
let's go back now how are you familiar
she can help with the baby department by
the way
she's got the right equipment yes i
agree just fyi are you familiar with
this only fan situation
you don't even know about it
please tell me because my one of my
children might be anyways
continue kids are going to see now
danielle's a pg
you know pg no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no bob if you don't
say they're definitely going to go to it
aoc has come out and said now officially
that you don't understand that
sex work is work yeah she tweeted that
yesterday she said sex work is worse
pardon me so basically she tweeted
yesterday saying sex work
is working does she know how sex workers
in many
uh ways are recruited you know how bad
she got trashed on twitter
when she said that she got crushed on
twitter yesterday but she got a retweet
from adam which was uh well we've been
talking oh for the love of
god yeah you're about to get
i'm about to hit the eject button mr tom
cruise you got to go you know
what direction i'm going over here i see
three don't want to have liking aoc's
tweets
i'm not liking her tweets i'm just and
and actually she you know you've seen
the shirts that
attacks the wrists she has taxed the
rich do you heard the shirt that i made
something i know
rhymes with rich yes tax the so that's
a young lady so facebook apple let's
wrap this up with facebook apple before
we go to the next stop yeah
what's going on this is actually a big
deal let me explain to you why
let me explain to you why so small
business so two two arguments on both
sides
arguments on both sides okay who has the
bigger monopoly
if you ask it would you say facebook
yeah
that was the good conversation who has
the bigger monopoly facebook or apple
who has more power
you say facebook what do you say i don't
know i mean with the whole 46
of smartphones i'm here okay okay so the
monopoly
is but they're not talking about
breaking up after we are talking about
breaking on facebook
go ahead to to go to facebook you have
to pick up
the apple iphone that to go to facebook
you got to pick up the
apple ipad to go to facebook you gotta
pick up your
apple mac pro you know whatever you want
to call it you have to go
all roads lead to apple okay
so the 46 buddy that's a lot of roads
but you're talking 54 dude you're
forgetting apps
music beats you're forgetting i
watch you forget apple watch you're
forgetting you're forgetting so many
different things that these guys are
just dominating the market with okay
plus if you have if you if you send
someone a text and it comes up green
they
make fun of you we we forced eric yeah
have you switched it or not
did you really switch oh my gosh that
scares me i interviewed the guy with 30
million subscribers who's the number one
tech guy on youtube that you know talks
about all these different things phones
that's coming out
actually i can't wait to for the viewers
to see it it was a great conversation
he's a genius but going back to this
okay
apple is pushing their weight around man
that's a scary thought it's a scary
scary thought and facebook has to be
very careful because facebook
needs apple and if apple wants to make
facebook's life a living hell they could
easily do it
so facebook has to be very very careful
because all roads don't lead to facebook
all roads lead to apple that leads to
facebook i have to go to appletown to
find facebook i don't go to facebook
town to find apple
to that part apple has facebook has to
keep in mind the other part
where facebook is right what facebook is
saying is right let me give facebook
side okay
a small business owner doesn't have a
lot of money to advertise
small business owners not advertising a
million dollars a month a small business
owner is advertising a thousand a week
two thousand a week five thousand a week
for them to not be able to target the
audience to their city
you know locations streets demographic
all that dude you're
so now i have to spend four times the
amount of money to find the niche market
that i want to find because now i can't
get
targeted at so the advertiser stops if
the small business owner stops
advertising to the targeted market that
they have
that that small business owner now takes
a hit so i understand
why facebook is siding with the small
business owner
but they also have to realize that king
kong in this situation
is apple you have to watch how you talk
to apple
it's that simple it's called it's called
free enterprise and competition bro
you're going to push them around you you
you have to be very very respectful when
you're dealing with apple
it's that simple and facebook may sound
like they're a caring
company but this also has to do true
they're you're right
absolutely sorry but what i'm saying is
i like the angle they took what they're
focusing on the small creators
small business owners i mean my gosh
right now in america sure
exactly i mean that's that's good pr i
get it but no you're right and in terms
of who who wears the pants you're
absolutely right if they were scared
like you're saying they have to they
need to be careful why are they taking
out full-page ads in newspapers
criticizing them isn't that the exact
opposite isn't that putting their [ __ ]
out there and saying
nah buddy we're going to come at you and
we're going to put you in all the major
publications
and we don't care what you have to say
because we're going to put it out there
what's what's their thought process
there if they were
um so so by the way just so you know
most of the audience
uh voted for apple over facebook is what
the audience said here
so yeah did you have did you have to
turn your mic because i can't hear you
no uh my only question there was because
apple obviously has been taking a
big like their big marketing effort in
privacy
yeah where they're marketing that we're
big on privacy so then
limiting the consumer and essentially
protecting the person from
somebody overstepping their bounds my
question for you would then be
um regardless of is facebook or apple
the bigger monopoly
who is overstepping their bounds more
facebook or apple
because you know the uh the whole when
people say they have their phone there
they talk about cat food and then
suddenly they're seeing cat food
commercials like even though
facebook's not even remotely open or
active on the app
it might be lingering on the back well
that part is a different story the whole
thing with
instagram got caught watching you with
their camera and then they said oh we're
so sorry
i have a problem with that that's a
different story that's the kind of that
is
what at least kind of how that's a
slippery slope that's what they're
trying to limit of basically saying that
you have to enable it
i don't i think there's other way i
think look i think there's a happy
medium
targeting if i'm targeting you based on
what some of the targeting i think the
small business owner only helps them out
no yeah but the targeting of camera
listen that's a that's criminal offense
that's the stuff that should go to court
you're recording what i'm doing what are
you talking about here exactly no that
that's that's a crime that's it
situation by the way you know you know
what happens if you work at a
retail store and you know the peep stuff
they would put cameras some employees
got cut you know what happens that's a
that's a federal offense you're going to
jail when you're putting the camera in
the
changing room oh yeah so that's pretty
much what they're doing they're putting
the camera in the changing room except
it's my bedroom
so if you enjoy this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye